how many bloody well for you something
like this happen we sure we support each
other
this is his history document this
history never had done before then look
back many many years ago and see what
Tyler Perry did this is for at night so
I'm glad to be part of my work I'll be
open to it you know young money we've
had lots of folks have been lots of
money and lots of things and never have
we had anyone who put together a studio
and said I'm going to do this not just
for the city on man but for those who
came before and all the folks that need
new jobs and I'm going to facilitate
this because we don't have to wait for a
job and he owns everything
I don't think years ago anyone would
dream that this can happen for an
african-american and so this is your
school and it is part of our history I
remember this being Fort McPherson just
to see all this change but this
community to see them and to know that
someone that looks like
it speaks like them that understands
their culture this entire building this
place this land these Lots it just keeps
them motivated I mean it was huge of him
to come here because he could have gone
anywhere this is so moving and so
meaningful he bringin power to the city
I've been a fan of Tyler's he's been a
friend of mine and I've been so proud of
him I'm still happy for his success and
I've always realized how important this
is awfully for black
best piece of advice that he's ever
given me is never take no for an answer
if it's something that you know you can
achieve I've learned it there's nobody
like him he does everything completely
unconventional and he's always trying to
empower other people it's astronomical
what he's been able to do knowing where
he started and where he's come to I
always believe it as you climb the
ladder you need to reach behind and pull
people up with you and he is the prime
example of that he had nothing going for
him but Frank he was unknown he was
unheard of he didn't have the capital he
just had the fellow and I think that is
an inspirational story for all Americans
that dreams can still be achieved in
spite of the vicissitudes of life from
him living in a car to now owning the
world and not only does he have for
himself he gives to everybody
and his mother I think about her
and he's so classy I'm feeling so much
gratitude I'm feeling so humbled by it
but I'm also looking at the line of cars
trying to get in wondering why they're
not filming going faster so my whole I'm
on I'm trying to be like stop and stop
relax to be in the moment so yeah cuz
Oprah's in one of those cars and Gayle
they're trying to get up here so they
got to move this line what I'm most
excited about is what this means to
Tyler
I mean he said he left Oprah's legends
ball feeling very inspired to do
something bigger grander she said that
he's now done that to the tenth power I
remember he was he's actually on tape
saying it as he was leaving the ball he
said I'm gonna leave here and I'm going
to dream a bigger joke I shall never
forget it and every time he does
something I say well you have fulfilled
that dream when I think all the years
about movie studios oh my goodness I
have never ever heard of a duty of
maintaining it and not always
a lot too many of us do it for us
it took Tyler Perry
[Music]
you
you